this season on David and Annie after the  90 days  oh my god well actually her first time  see a dead body of the chicken  today David going to become among I had  a hair transplant I just hope they come  back thicker than they were before  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  we are taking Amber and Jordan down to  Phuket Thailand so we can enroll the  kids in an English language school when  they go to the NBC next time boom get  the visa exactly  to be in America you have to have a big  mouth  while we're here in Phuket we can expose  them to Western food Western culture  something they could not find in their  Village in bundan yeah  foreign  and all of a sudden he stormed off we  just don't know what to do with him  with the last period like for three  months I didn't have my period  I didn't think I would ever think about  being a father again  this is a womb can you see holy cow what  I am doing  [Music]  foreign